[Music]
one
two cracks
[Music]
in this video i'm going to show you four
different ways to achieve very
complicated very expensive looking
camera shots with some affordable
creative makeshift camera setups
for this very slick little 360 camera
the insta 360 one x2 which retails for
only like 430 bucks
i honestly feel by adding this little
piece of gear to my arsenal
the game is about to be changed entirely
[Music]
you might be wondering why i'm wearing a
completely different jacket that's
because this shot was shot
five days after that shot because the
video is done now and there's something
that i forgot to add
which is that all the shots you're about
to see were shot in 4k
50 frames i wanted to utilize the 50
frames so that i could slow down the
footage
but for all of those that want to make
the footage look a little bit more crisp
there is the option to shoot at 5.7 k
25 frames and at the end of this video i
will put in a snippet
showing you what that looks like cool
in the industry you would usually use a
fully kitted out truck with a remote
crane attached to it
like this to shoot really smooth and
fluid car shots where you can feel the
road at the bottom of frame as well as
get really close to the decals
etc but instead i'm going to suspend
myself on this harness at the back of my
truck
swinging around this one x2 360 camera
on this three meter pole while i shoot
swooping cinematic shots for a fake
commercial
of my friend jared driving this ac curb
is applied to me by the guys
at ac cobra in cape town if you ever
looking for a car like this to cruise
around in
you can check them out in my description
let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
dude if this thing snaps i died
[Music]
[Music]
so badly okay that's a wrap on this shot
let's see how it looks
hmm
tabletop food shots are great addition
to your full making skill set you can
make many
at-home commercials for different food
brands as well as who doesn't enjoy
a great cinematic breakfast montage this
little camera lets you get into tight
spaces that you'd usually only be able
to achieve with a probe lens attached to
a really expensive cinema camera
i got my good friend rubes to simply
make some breakfast and see how epic i
can make it look
on this camera
[Music]
[Music]
what we're doing for the scene is
creating a snorri cam
effect which is when you attach the
camera to the object
which essentially makes you feel like
the object
which is cool really immerses you into
the piece
it's another advantage of this camera is
it's waterproof
[Music]
and cut the bread
nice one bru let's see what that looks
[Music]
like
so
breakfast is saved thank you
[Music]
for this next scene i'm going to utilize
this bullet time cord to shoot a 360
degree
rotation around me while i surf if it
all works out it should look pretty cool
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my word dan lost a 360 camera
that is so bad
i should have realized when i threw it
in the beginning
i flying over my hand my hands are too
cold i got up on a wave
didn't even do one rotation camera's
gone bruh
won't try that again luckily we got one
more camera
for the final scene i'm going to combine
all three techniques
the three meter long human jib shot the
snory cam and the bullet time shot to
shoot a music video scene
of the joe films band
don't worry about me you found that [ __ ]
when you add all those elements together
it looks something like this
[Music]
yes
before signing out this video i said i
would show you what it looks like at
5.7k shooting 25 frames a second so
yeah this is 5.7k 25 frames
a second nice and crisp and there you
have it i waited till the edit was done
so that i could say this with confidence
that
this little piece of gear is a must-have
in your arsenal
if you're wanting to create cool [ __ ]
easily
please let me know in the comments below
if there's a piece of gear you would
like me to review next or if you've
created a piece of gear that you would
like me to review you can send it to the
address that i've placed in the
description below
like this video comment and subscribe it
all helps with the algorithm
and other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and i'll see you next week
is